you want to know what kind of force can
tear a planet apart it was you take a
look you see an earth that can be shaved
[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my agents
of shield premier Easter eggs so it's
from actually the first two episodes
because they did them back-to-back
instead of just doing one episode so if
you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
agents of shield is now a Friday night
show they've confirmed that it's gonna
be a full season but there were some big
twists that will help them deal with
what's going on with infinity war next
year and obviously like the big twist of
the episode is an infinity war twist so
there were a bunch of Easter eggs for
The Avengers movies so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the
episodes yet we'll also have to talk
about stuff specifically during the
latest phase three movies so if you're
not caught up on the movies we will be
talking about that stuff but now someone
has used a different type of a bolus to
transport them forward about 90 years
into the future but they're still on
earth but earth had been quaked apart as
they say in that footage and then the
Kree came in and basically took over
this part of space and just started
mining it for water precious minerals
sort of turned what was left of humanity
into a Logan's Run situation so if you
haven't seen Logan's run in a while like
they all have jewels in their arms so
like when the colors change on their
little bands there and everybody loses
their talking about renewal that's
a Logan's Run thing where it's like
we're trying to help humanity but really
they're suppressing it the whole thing
about the space station that they're in
is that it's not a space station at all
it was an underground bunker that when
the planet got quaked apart became a
space station that they just repurposed
so when Coulson is making all those
jokes about Howard Stark and Stark
technology having stuff going on in
outer space technically he's not wrong
it's just that Stark built that as an
underground bunker that they're using as
a space station in the future so this is
how the TV show is dealing with the
events of infinity war next year they're
basically
taking all the characters off the planet
and into the far future so that they
don't have to worry about trying to
address
Thanos coming to New York City and then
not being able to put those characters
in the movies so we can all joke about
the defenders next year and how they're
going to avoid talking about Thanos
literally coming to New York City to get
the infinity gems but hopefully that
explains how the planet was quaked apart
and what the tragedy surrounding that
was it was basically the events of
infinity war in something caused Daisy
Johnson to quake the planet apart so
it's implied that she was participating
in infinity war and something happened
to make her lose her mind with probably
the mind gem so if you haven't seen
previous seasons they've actually made
references to her being able to do that
like she does have what you would call
Omega level abilities it's just that she
hasn't unlocked those yet so she is one
of the more powerful Inhumans that's on
the planet but the TV show just hasn't
pushed into that yet so now it's
basically saying that that happened
during infinity war Thanos unlocked
those abilities and used her to destroy
the planet but I think the big reason
behind that is so that the people on
that space station that they're on hate
her if they find out so it gives her
something to feel regretful about like
it adds some drama to the situation like
oh my god I'm the one that destroyed the
planet you probably detected all the
Star Wars guardians of the galaxy stuff
going on where like there were some very
advanced pieces of technology like the
ship design looked like it was right out
of the guardians of the galaxy movie but
there's a very original trilogy Star
Wars vibe about everything where it
seems like it's really old but they're
all in the future there was also a bunch
of stuff from the Thor movies there's
also some Thor Ragnarok references going
on here too like Earth isn't a place
it's a people somebody should tell that
to the agents of shield people but
obviously they're gonna try and save the
earth and I think that's part of the
idea it's a relatively optimistic series
so they're probably gonna find out what
happened travel back into the past by
the end of the season and then fix
everything but they made all kinds of
references to Ghost Rider to magic to
things that they thought were the big
twist behind what was going on like
magic flaming skull you don't think that
has anything to do with what's going on
and then people like Simmons make jokes
like oh wow
biologists but sure I can invent time
travel in the next couple of minutes
just give me a sec so for the time being
they're stuck where they are until they
find a similar obelisk that can send
them back through time but I think the
idea is is it super rare and they're not
gonna find it for a long time but
starting at the beginning of the episode
just going through all the big Easter
eggs so I've already talked about a lot
of the infinity war stuff that was going
on but yo-yo makes a joke about sword
she says don't you guys have some sort
of moon base which is talking about a
tool and in the in humans or some
space-based agency called spear she's
talking about sword the reason why they
probably can't mention sword is is
because either Fox has the rights to
that I think it also has something to do
with the idea that they're not doing
that this season which is the time
travel explainer like if it hadn't have
been time travel if they were just in
outer space they probably would have
done sword in the roaches as they call
them the Ridley Scott alien looking
creatures are deep cuts from the Thor
comics so it's not the brood and what
happened is is after the earth exploded
they basically moved in as scavengers
but as Max says there's a big Ridley
Scott alien Easter Egg haven't you all
watch the alien movies don't you know
what happens when the group splits up
you know who's gonna die first making
the joke about the black guy dying first
you get your star-lord reference when
deke comes in he's the reluctant hero
obviously he's gonna help them out but
they use the framework from last season
to sort of drug people and make them
feel like things aren't so bad so that's
how they travel back into the past and
they find some records about history and
what happened and they drop that
infinity war bomb for those of you
asking about what's going on with Fitz
there are a number of ways that he could
come back so it's possible that he put
himself into cryo sleep and he's hidden
somewhere and he'll wake up in present
day like oh I've just been sleeping this
whole time trying to find you guys again
but from the look of everything they're
gonna be doing everything set in the
future so either Fitz shows up inside
the framework or he shows up in present
day while they're in the future so I
don't think they're gonna spend too much
time flashing back as far as we know the
villain of the season is going to be
this creep overseer so it's sort of a
snowpiercer situation where the front of
the Train like the top of this Space
Station place lives really well the Kree
live really well in everybody down in
the bottom
lives really terribly the whole idea of
them taking it this far into the future
though in outer space means that they
can do a lot of the other alien races in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so they
can do Kree they can even do the
sovereign characters but they're so
xenophobic and they're so about
perfection that I don't think that they
would even want to associate with any of
the Kree even though the Kree here the
overseer is acting a little bit like the
sovereign but as you can see they pull
Easter eggs from all over the place so
there'll be star wars there'll be
classic earth-based Marvel films they'll
be the space based Marvel films that
we've had in Phase three like Thor
Ragnarok guardians of the galaxy one and
two but aside from Ghost Rider
references those were all the big Easter
eggs and if you're wondering if Ghost
Rider is coming back they did
specifically reference during the
episode the Coulson's deal with the
rider would come due at a certain point
so that's the way they're going to bring
Ghost Rider back the spirit of vengeance
will fill him but because of this twist
we don't know what's going on with Robby
Reyes so the war he was talking about at
the end of last season was infinity war
but now that they're in the future it
sounds like they've taken a different
spin on that and even though the rider
would keep Robby ray is alive so he
would be alive in 90 years but I don't
think that's going to happen till much
later this season I think that when they
mentioned that in the first episode it
was just for shadowing for stuff that
we're becoming much much later well let
me know in the comments if you spotted
any other big Marvel Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video and let me
know what you thought of the episode
what do you think of the big twist this
season and do you think that this will
bring a lot of people back because
they're being so crazy and so integrated
with the twists of infinity war I've got
some new flash season 4 reverse flash
and infinity war that I'll be posting in
the next couple of days but leave all
your Marvel requests in the comments
below and there will be a new round of
the giveaway when I post that flash
video in a couple hours but while you
wait for everything you can click here
to re-watch the Infinity war trailer and
you can click here for the teaser for
Robin in the new Titans TV series they
finally drop the first look
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you